oh I'm the chef that loves a challenge
this is a toy the marshmallow explosion
welcome back to chef's out of water I'm
Alexis a chef who's always up for a
challenge
that's why I've taken to the Internet
for you to decide what I should cook
with next at the end there'll be a
surprise guest who will have to guess
what I used to make the meal I don't
know who I'm cooking for and they don't
know what appliance I'm using so let's
get to it
an easy bake oven this is crazy there's
there's like not even a full inch of
space my hand is bigger than this tray
this is this is a joke as a kid I dreamt
about having an easy bake oven and now
my dream is my nightmare Oh No okay it's
gonna be fine
I think I have a plan we'll see if it
works before the first course I'm going
to make a personal pizza to make it
really delicious I'm gonna start off
making my own dough so I've got my warm
water I just sprinkle some yeast over it
and let it bloom
meantime I'm gonna whisk my sugar salt
and olive oil this is gonna be a really
simple quick ditto you can tell when
these blooming because still start to
bubble a little yeast looks foamy and
good gonna add that to the oil and
adding the flour I just had that self it
Pizza usually cooks really really high
temperatures the internet told me this
only gets to 350 so pizza dough pizza
dough might be a bad idea maybe if I
rolled the dough out super thin I'm
gonna let this rise in this oiled Bowl
while my pizza dough Rises I'm gonna get
started on my next course because it's
gonna take a long time for my next
course I'm going to do nachos I had this
idea that I could make my own tortilla
chips by just cutting the tortillas
brushing them with oil and hopefully
they'll crisp up in the Easy Bake Oven
let's see how this guy's gonna add some
spices to my ground beef some salt
garlic powder onion powder chili powder
paprika and I guess I'll just mix it
ground beef needs to cook to 160 degrees
so it should be able to work in here I
just don't know how long it'll take and
again I don't think it's gonna get that
browning I have a feeling that might be
kind of gray I'm gonna check on these
strips
oh okay it's not quite there but it's
actually kind of working like there's
some crispy yes here okay but here's the
thing it's gonna take me like three
hours just to make chips is there any
way that I can have some help my
sous-chef turns out to be my best friend
yeah and I got one too okay so the first
step we have to preheat it okay oh I
know this is crazy
mm-hmm but we have to do it like two
chips at a time I think well I work on
chips I'll have you work on ground beef
I mean how crispy do you need chips to
be really you know what I think we can
pivot to mini tacos that's cool I think
it's time to check oh it's like oh wait
I can do oh okay Wow okay this is this
is kind of good I know I'm shocked okay
we have a long way to go um but I think
if you keep doing the beef yeah it'll be
good okay I'm gonna cut out some mini
tortillas from the big boot because this
doesn't fit in the slop but this does so
so yeah ok wait this is actually this is
like a chip why is that so much better I
don't know
ok I'm gonna stick mattress this one
goes back you're getting so good at this
huh beautiful I have two chips
that looks great well your beef Wow
we've done we've done one thing so we've
got two in here one in here so we're
actually almost a ton it should only
take 25 minutes for the person 1 talking
okay if you can remove the casein and
crumble it up gonna do it the same way
that the ground beef you're thinking of
sausage pepper onion pizza feels a
little ambitious now but I think the
pepper and onion can just be will kind
of roast wait oh this is smoking
one very crispy chip you know it's fine
it's fine it'll be on the bottom of the
pile some people that would be their
favorite job yep these are beautiful
chips love it all right I'm gonna do
nine chips that feels sufficient oh wow
this dough is Wow it's feisty she's
doing well I think we're coming to the
part of nervous about okay if you can
get that cookie cutter and stamp out two
circles circles okay can you check the
sausage it's done first do you think
it's all sutures ready
whoa yeah amazing amazing it's like a
real pizza here I'll check this out
my confidence level about the pizza is a
seven oh you know I'm happy for you
gladly I just took these onions out we
have it actually looks it looks really
good
I'll fit - it smells like very dewy okay
okay these look these look amazing
I mean this is yeah Wow oh my god the
bottom has some Brown there I mean this
smells it smells amazing it's it's kind
of more like focaccia than pizza but
thank you so much can't wait to see Ryan
was the biggest help I could have ever
asked for this time start plating
this is pre-made sauce I've got some
mozzarella and some of my toppings I'm
so excited for this person to guess what
I used like they're gonna have no idea
this is actually really fun
I made a mini pizza with real pizza
dough in an easy-bake oven making food
with the kids joy is so out of my
element but I feel elated
there was a cheese ball
did you see it one of my favorite
after-school snacks was cookies every
single day so this this definitely needs
a sweet element so I'm gonna make a
crispy rice Zac I'm just gonna cut some
marshmallows some butter it's got my
marshmallows on and pop them in I'm
gonna layer the nachos with obviously
chips cheese my ground beef got some
black beans tomatoes and avocado
[Music]
it seems to be a bit of a marshmallow
explosion oh shoot okay okay fine fine
fine pressure this I feel better about
this this looks good
gonna add chocolate chips I'm gonna go
find a cookie cutter and like put this
into a keychain oh my god this is so
cute okay I've been told that the taste
testers here and they're ready to try
and I can't wait to see if they can
guess what I've used my name is Jonas
and I'm nine years old the first time
Alexis cooked for me was on I draw you
cook robot episodes we heard you really
like robots next we actually love it I
think it looks so weird and cool the
cookie dish that's mine today
Alexis made three snacks for me and I
have to guess what she used to make I'm
so proud of everything I made and I
can't wait to see what this taste tester
thanks let's bring him out you something
wow it's so good to see you again
Eugene how's it going for your first
after-school snack you have nachos
boom just like that oh great
on a scale of one to ten what would you
give these nachos an eight great I'll
take it
you've got mini pizzas with sausage
pepper and onion just tastes like pizza
yeah yeah maybe the crust would be a
little hard I think that's a fair
assessment on a scale of one to ten what
would you give this Pizza six fair are
you ready for your last no you go again
a ten okay so we've got an eight a six
and A ten I think that's pretty good
I like Nick is it that you put tomato oh
you don't like tomato tomato and this
was kind of hard to eat it like to bite
it off mmm as you can see okay so now
that you've tried all three snacks what
do you think I used to make them
a pan valiant valiant choice oh I know a
rolling pin for the mid oh I definitely
used a rolling pin what do you think I
used to cook it myself
stove oh I know I'm oven okay well I've
got some news for you I basically used a
kid's toy to make all three of these no
I did it
you used a kid's toy yeah this is what I
used to make this I am so impressed with
this dish thanks Eunice hi
I did make a fatal mistake of not
actually trying the chips so they're
really hard
I still make chips in an easy-bake oven
okay the chips are fairly inedible but
overall I think this day was such a
success I feel so proud and excited and
I just had absolutely no idea that any
of this was possible and you know I know
I said Easy Bake Ovens were a nightmare
but I think I just fulfilled a childhood
fantasy comment below and let me know
what you make in your Easy Bake Ovens
[Music]